أريد أن أسألك شيئًا
قالته نيكي هالي في وقت سابق اليوم في وقت سابق من هذا
الصباح عندما سُئلت في مقابلة عما إذا
كان الحزب الجمهوري حزبًا عنصريًا
وكان ردها وأنا أقتبس منها
الآن، نحن لسنا دولة عنصرية ولم نكن
أبدًا  دولة عنصرية هل توافق على
أن الولايات المتحدة لم تكن أبدًا
دولة عنصرية حسنًا الولايات المتحدة أه ليست
دولة عنصرية وقد تغلبنا على أشياء في
تاريخنا كما تعلم أعتقد أن
الآباء المؤسسين وضعوا مجموعة من
المبادئ التي هي  عالمية
الآن لم يتم
تطبيقها عالميًا في ذلك الوقت ولكن أعتقد أنهم
فهموا ما كانوا يفعلونه لقد
فهموا أن هذه المبادئ ستكون
محرك التقدم
للأجيال القادمة وهذا ما
حدث، أعتقد أن
الحزب الجمهوري أه يقف  من أجل الجدارة والإنجاز
وعمى الألوان، هذا
ما يجب أن ندافع عنه، على سبيل المثال
في فلوريدا، لقد قمت بإلغاء أشياء في
جامعاتنا مثل هذه
ويقولون إنها تنوع ومساواة وشمول
ولكنها حقًا أيديولوجية للغاية
وهم يحاولون ذلك  فرض أجندة
أعتقد أن الطريقة التي يتم بها ممارستها فعليًا
تمثل التمييز والإقصاء
والتلقين وهذا خطأ. دعونا لا
نقسم الناس على أساس العرق أو العرق
أو الجنس. دعونا نتعامل مع الناس
كأفراد وليس كأعضاء في مجموعة
بالطبع سنجتمع جميعًا معًا.
ويقولون إنه لا ينبغي أن يكون هناك أي
تمييز ضد أي شخص بناءً
على ذلك، ولكن هذا لا يقتصر على
التمييز ضد الأقليات العرقية أو العرقية
بالطبع، فأنت لا تفعل ذلك، بل
يعني أيضًا أنك لا تمارس التمييز
ضد الأمريكيين البيض أو في بيئة
الجامعة التي لا تفعلها.  لا
أميز ضد الأمريكيين الآسيويين
لمجرد أنهم يميلون إلى الحصول على
أداء عالٍ، لذا يجب استعادة الإنجاز الفردي
والاستحقاق في هذا
البلد، المجتمع المصاب بعمى الألوان هو ما
يجب أن نطمح إليه، وهذا ما
سأفعله كرئيس، أريد فقط  للتوضيح،
المحافظ يريد فقط التوضيح، هل
تتفق مع نيكي هيلي في أن الولايات المتحدة
لم تكن أبدًا دولة عنصرية؟ حسنًا،
ما قلته هو أننا واجهنا تحديات تتعلق
بكيفية النظر إلى العرق، وعلى سبيل
المثال، كانت تلك مبادئ عالمية
في الإعلان  الاستقلال وكان
لديك قرار في خمسينيات القرن التاسع عشر،
قالت قضية دريد سكوت إن دريد سكوت
لأنه كان أسودًا لم يكن
مواطنًا أمريكيًا، وكان ذلك خطأً كان
تمييزًا على أساس العرق
ولهذا السبب انتهى بك الأمر إلى
التصديق على التعديل الرابع عشر لإلغائه  دريد
سكوت، نعم، لقد واجهنا تحديات تتعلق بكيفية
تعاملنا مع العرق
كمجتمع ولكننا سنكون بغض النظر عن
خلفيتك إذا كان
لديك مكان واحد تريد أن تنمو فيه
وتتمتع بأكبر قدر من الفرص المتاحة.  بغض
النظر عن خلفيتك، فهذا هو أفضل
مكان لتنمو فيه وتحقق
أحلامك في أي مكان في العالم بأكمله